yeah there's like a very like hello
would you like to buy a car oh I meant
to that I pretty much only ask people
out over text I know I've never called
someone to ask them I think the only
people I call on the phone or like my
mom or that's it
in middle school I would talk on the
phone with this girl I had a crush it
was like the kind of dance when it was
like girls asked the guys out you can
look at a text and then kind of reply in
your own leisure but like when you're on
the phone you can hear their response I
met him about a month ago when I went
bowling and I thought he was really cute
and I thought he was really funny I'm
just gonna ask out someone who I met two
nights ago we had a good conversation
she might be at work so that could be a
problem we were in the same dorm last
year you really like soccer and
basketball I love soccer and basketball
we both love anime this guy's kind of a
perfect guy this girl that I went to
high school with and throughout college
we kind of went back and forth on saying
that we should catch up I have a crush
on him for a very specific reason that
I'm not gonna say on the Internet
contemporary American fare and mixology
focused cocktails in the mid-century
modern space with a patio I'm available
next Friday I want to know if you wanted
to go out with me if you'd like to go
out with me well if he doesn't pick up I
think it would be rude to leave it in a
voicemail frogs like licking you cuz
your fly let's go to the beach
I don't know the worst thing that can
happen if someone says no to me I'll
move on alright about it in my journal
I'll go to therapy about it I'll be fine
I think
I haven't gotten these kinds of
ringtones in a long time what smell I
it's Catherine it's uh yeah it's been
it's been a while how have you been how
are you um good how's your day going hey
were you up to you right now well I mean
just in general but like yes are you
busy just just got back from work that's
cool that's cool work is fun
hey this is rocky I was just hanging out
listening to that giant dog album you've
been telling me about so I wanted to say
that I'm available next Friday and I was
wondering if you'd like to go out so you
can call me back or text me you bought
your own bowling ball I'm just chilling
on a couch you know doing what I do is
just hanging out at work this is Jordan
the ginger dude you met at the mixer a
couple nights ago I thought you were
pretty cool and pretty cute and I would
love to take you out for a drink
sometime next week I just finally like
kind of build up the confidence to ask
you on a date so I was calling to see if
you wanted to get drinks sometime hey
I've wanted to ask you a question when
you come to LA if you wanted to like go
to the beach you know we'll go play some
like soccer on the beach and then you
know watch some avatar last airbender
Legend of Korra I don't know just hang
out and stuff so um I was wondering if
I'm sorry I don't come being really
weird do you wanna like go out sometime
like
okay cool yeah we could uh yeah cool um
[Music]
cool right now I'm freed Monday or
Tuesday if you give me a call back if
you're free thanks bye
oh this is not Netflix and chill hey
we're having a good day and it could
year so far and talk to you later bye
bye well as a date no dude that's that's
fine okay not a Netflix and chill but
Netflix and just begin you know Netflix
and just like have fun but not sexual
fun what all right cool um awesome well
I just have a little bit of a cold I
don't normally sell this high-pitched
hey sounds good good alright I just got
friend-zoned it's cool
oh no you guys are making me sad
voicemail yeah there's a bit of that
kind of relief and then intense anxiety
of like oh now you have to do a
monologue that will stand on its own you
said yes now I feel really good I don't
feel like I get the same satisfaction as
someone who's like okay I either get an
acceptance or rejection now it's just
like to erase and rerecord
[Music]